ja und über das Thema spreche ich jetzt
mit Lamia messari Becker Professorin für
Gebäudetechnologie und Bauphysik an der
Universität Siegen schönen guten Morgen
schönen guten Morgen wir haben gesehen
es gibt offenbar so eine Art Comeback
der Kohle und Holzöfen wie bewerten sie
das
das ist natürlich
klimaschutzpolitisch alles andere als
schön
ob das Gas oder Öl oder jetzt Kohle und
Holz das sind alles natürlich fossile
Quellen und für den Klimaschutz ist es
natürlich eine
Verschlechterung völlig klar aber in
dieser mangelage in der wir
wahrscheinlich jetzt noch reinkommen im
Winter ist die Verunsicherung groß und
es gibt nicht viele Alternativen leider
würden sie dann Menschen dazu raten
tatsächlich sofort zu sorgen vielleicht
auch Gas und Ölheizungen auszutauschen
ich würde auf jeden Fall dazu raten dass
man die Einsparmaßnahmen die man selbst
generieren kann erheben soll
beispielsweise durch die Einstellung der
Heizungsanlage dass sie gut und
effizient arbeitet beispielsweise durch
die Dämmung der Heizungsrohre und wenn
es geht auch in der Heizperiode 1 oder 2
Grad weniger zu heizen vielleicht auch
nur bestimmte Räume die man unbedingt
braucht bis hin zu der Maßnahme dass man
die Heizperiode um einen Monat später
beginnt all das ist wichtig also jede
Kilowattstunde die wir sparen ist
wichtig aber auch jede Kilowattstunde
die wir erzeugen das wäre dann die
Aufgabe der Politik jetzt haben sie über
das Heizen schon gesprochen was könnte
ich denn momentan vielleicht sogar schon
tun um Energie einzusparen weil in den
heizmonaten sind wir ja noch nicht
genau aber was jetzt schon passieren
kann ist beispielsweise dass die
öffentliche Hand der öffentliche Gebäude
Freibäder und etliche andere
Verwaltungsgebäude auch in dem Bereich
der Beleuchtung der Klimatisierung der
Lüftung der Warmwasserbereitung dass man
da auch einiges einsparen kann glaube
ich das ist schon angekommen und das
müssen jetzt auch die Kommunen vor Ort
umsetzen also da gibt es auch einiges
was man einsparen kann bevor wir dann
bei den privaten Haushalten im Winter
dann weitermachen wenn wir jetzt an
diese öffentlichen Gebäude denken wie
viel kann man da sparen wie groß ist
sozusagen die die Range wie wie
ertragreich ist das
das ist eine gute Frage das kann im
Moment kaum jemand beziffern aber wir
müssen auch unterscheiden es gibt
beispielsweise Freibäder die man wenn
man sie gar nicht heizt dann ist
natürlich die Einsparung für den
konkreten Fall 100% wenn man im
öffentlichen Gebäude kein
Warmwasserbereitung keine
Warmwasserbereitung mehr bereithält dann
spart man vielleicht bis 15 Prozent also
die die einsparmaßen sind sehr
unterschiedlich und das ist eigentlich
auch ein Teil der Notlage in der wir
sind man kann nicht genau sagen wie viel
spart man am Ende und ich verweise auch
darauf dass im Winter wir kaum wissen
wie klemmt man welche Adressaten ab also
haben wir irgendwo ein Schieber oder
müssen wir eher über Vollzug setzen also
im Moment tappen wir im Dunkeln
tatsächlich können Sie noch mal ein Tipp
geben was sozusagen ich als Privatperson
dann noch zu Hause machen kann neben dem
was jetzt schon gesagt haben in Bezug
auf die Heizung
auf jeden Fall schauen dass wir die
Nachtabsenkung haben im Winter bis dahin
sollte die Heizung einmal general
geprüft werden und eingestellt werden
Heizkörper entlüftet werden bis hin zu
Dämmung vielleicht von nicht ausgebauten
Dachböden man muss sich das vorstellen
die oberste Decke die Flachdecke
unterhalb eines Daches wenn es nicht
ausgebaut ist die Dämmung dieser Decke
kann man tatsächlich in Eigenarbeit
machen das ist relativ einfach und spart
eigentlich im Heizbedarf eines Gebäudes
bis zu 20 Prozent ab 2024 sollen ja neue
Hausheizungen hauptsächlich mit
erneuerbaren Energien laufen heizen ohne
fossile Energiequellen inwieweit wird
das denn zu schaffen sein wie schätzen
Sie das ein und vor allem wie schnell
das wird meiner Ansicht nach nicht zu
schaffen sein schon gar nicht ab 2024
denn die
Alternativen sind noch nicht da man muss
sehen dass wir im Wärmebereich gerade
mal 15 Prozent Anteil erneuerbare
Energien haben und wir laufen jetzt im
Winter nicht nur in eine Wärme Lücke
sondern auch in eine Stromlücke wo soll
das alles herkommen im Moment sind
tatsächlich die alternativen sehr rau
und deshalb plädiere ich dafür dass man
eventuell nicht nur auf Gebäude sitzt
sondern auch auf kommunale Maßnahmen
Fernwärme quartiersansätze also das
nicht jeder sein einziges Objekt
sozusagen anschaut sondern in der Größe
versucht sich zusammen zu tun sagt lamir
missari Becker Professorin für
Gebäudetechnologie und Bauphysik an der
Universität Siegen vielen Dank fürs
Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen